merci beaucoup d'être avec nous durant
cette demi-heure et lui du compte
allemand du groupe Union centriste vous
êtes vice-président de la délégation
collectivité territoriale et à la
décentralisation et président du
Parlement rural français on va en parler
on l'a vu dans le journal Emmanuel
Macron qui a donc passé une grande
partie de sa journée avec les mères hier
il a notamment fait une déambulation de
4 heures dans le salon des mers la
méthode est inédites c'est la bonne
méthode pour vous alors les maires de
France et présidents d'intercommunalité
puisque congrès s'adresse aussi à eux
étaient habitué à avoir depuis très
longtemps et tout président confondu
avoir un discours un long discours
devant eux une autre méthode a été
choisie cette année que je trouve
intéressantes c'est parcourir le salon
présent par la République à paru salon
ce qui a permis au maire quel qu'il soit
des villes des métropoles mais aussi des
des petites communes de pouvoir discuter
en direct échanger en direct faire part
en direct au président de la République
de la réalité de leur territoire de leur
commune de leurs préoccupation donc je
trouve ça vraiment bien et en tous les
cas je pense que ça a été apprécié
apprécié par les maires cet échange
vraiment direct avec le président et je
pense aussi que c'est la bonne méthode
pour que le président s'approprie bien
la réalité des problématiques
rencontrent les maires y compris dans
les titres communes on est dans un
tournant dans les relations entre
l'exécutif et les mers en Emmanuel
Macron et les maires il y a une
différence entre ce premier ce second
quinquennat le premier oui je le crois
je pense que il y a certains nombre
d'événements qui sont passés par là
il y a eu il y a eu la crise sanitaire
où les maires ont été vraiment en
première ligne avec des présidents de
départements d'ailleurs je dois le dire
et on a montré que la proximité le rôle
du maire dans ces communes grandes et
petites c'était vraiment essentiel
il y a eu le le grand débat qui a fait
suite à la crise des gilets jaunes il y
a les maintenant les problèmes que l'on
rencontre avec l'énergie donc je pense
que le de la République a parfaitement
conscience que les maires jouent un rôle
tout à fait déterminant et que cet
échelon local est un échelon qui est
indispensable à la vie démocratique et
au service apporté à nos concitoyens
donc oui je crois que il y a une
évolution sur ce plan-là et que les
événements ils ont contribué et on va
parler tout de suite des préoccupations
des maires puisque Emmanuel Macron c'est
beaucoup qui était de leur moral et
évidemment les maires qui lui ont
quasiment tous dit que leur
préoccupations c'était là où se débris
et notamment la hausse des prix de
l'énergie et justement il en a été
beaucoup question hier au Sénat puisque
vous examinez en ce moment le budget on
va voir tout ça avec notre journaliste
parlementaire ça vient de chien
[Musique]
bonjour Samia bonjour Oriane bonjour
Bernard decro bonjour et Samia vous avez
donc suivi l'examen du budget hier au
Sénat avec un temps fort le vote de la
revalorisation de la dotation pour les
communes oui les sénateurs ont introduit
une augmentation plus importante que
prévu de la DGF la dotation globale de
fonctionnement c'est en fait l'enveloppe
que l'État vers chaque année au
collectivités locales et donc aux
communes le Sénat a voté son indexation
vous l'avez dit sur l'inflation alors
pourquoi cette année cette DGF dotation
globale de fonctionnement est fixée
après de 27 milliards d'euros soit une
augmentation de 320 millions d'euros par
rapport à l'année précédente la première
augmentation depuis 13 ans félicite le
gouvernement sauf que ce n'est pas du
tout assez pour les sénateurs 320
millions d'euros supplémentaires c'est
une augmentation d'un peu plus de 1% on
est donc en fait assez loin du niveau de
l'inflation pour l'instant évaluer la
4,3% écoutez l'intervention d'Eric
Kerrouche hier soir dans l'hémicycle
il faut que cette DGF puisse bien
entendu
aller au même rythme que que l'inflation
deux chiffres néanmoins pour appeler
l'importance de cette mesure entre 2017
et 2021 la non-adexation a représenté un
manque à gagner de l'ordre de 4
milliards d'euros sur la trajectoire que
l'on connaît actuellement au regard de
la conjoncture ces pertes pourraient
monter jusqu'à 10 milliards d'euros
entre 2022 et 2027 ce manque à gagner
est intolérable pour les collectivités
qui voient remettre en cause leurs
capacité d'action au quotidien les
sénateurs ils l'ont donc voté en cette
indexation de la dotation commune sur
l'inflation ce qui revient en fait à
augmenter la DGF de 1,1 milliard d'euros
en 2023 si on se base sur une inflation
donc à 4,3%, c'est donc une augmentation
qui est plus de trois fois supérieure à
celle prévue par l'exécutif à la base
c'est indexation elle a été votée contre
la vie du gouvernement mais aussi contre
la vie de la commission des finances du
Sénat elle a estimé en fait que les
communes ne peuvent pas demander en même
temps des aides exceptionnelles pour
payer leurs factures énergétique et
l'indexation de leur dotation sur
l'inflation en d'autres termes il faut
savoir choisir ses combats c'est
justifier Jean-François Husson le
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances
dans notre ADN dans le groupe de
lyocentriste nous avons l'équité et
l'équité fiscale l'équité pour les
collectivités et l'équité ce n'est pas
traité tout le monde de la même façon
l'équité c'est tenir compte des
différences et aider plus ceux qui ont
plus besoin d'une façon générale ça vaut
pour les collectivités et donc
aujourd'hui face à l'os des prix toutes
les collectivités ne sont pas logées à
la même enseigne vous avez des
territoires dans les grandes métropoles
notamment qui connaissent une croissance
démographique une croissance économique
qui génère des recettes fiscales
supplémentaires importantes j'ajoute que
cette année les bases fiscales avec des
mécanismes sont en place on va augmenter
de
6,5%. donc ces collectivités là peuvent
davantage faire face à l'augmentation
des prix que des petites collectivités
dans des territoires où il n'y a pas de
croissance économique et démographique
et donc peu de richesses fiscale et qui
elle doivent être aidé davantage donc
moi je défendais et notre groupe avec
une augmentation de la DGF ciblée les
territoires et les collectivités qui en
ont le plus besoin voilà qu'elle était
notre position c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose nous ne pensons
je dirais pas ça mais nous pensons que
les 320 millions d'euros qui étaient
prévus par le gouvernement qui était
ciblés sur les collectivités qui en ai
besoin c'est-à-dire sur la péréquation
en fait c'est 300 mêmes étaient ciblés
sur les collectivités qui bénéficient de
la péréquation ancienne bénéficie d'un
perquation c'est de la solidarité
nationale donc c'est quasiment besoin
moi j'avais déposé d'amendements
d'ailleurs pour augmenter le montant de
cette enveloppe en faveur des
collectivités qui en ont besoin bon
c'est un autre choix qui a été fait que
je comprends aussi par ailleurs en tous
les cas voilà le sens de notre position
et parce que le texte évidemment revenir
à l'Assemblée il y aura d'ailleurs
sûrement un nouveau un 49-3 le
gouvernement était opposé à ce qui a été
voté hier est-ce que vous espérez un
compromis ou est-ce que vous êtes un peu
résigné sur le fait que ça va revenir à
une augmentation de 320 millions alors
moi j'espère qu'il y aura des des
accords ce que je souhaite en chacun
encore une fois c'est que on n'est pas
une augmentation uniforme pour toutes
les collectivités mais quand bien aidé
celle qui en ont besoin donc celles qui
sont bénéficiaires de la péréquation ça
ça me paraît être la justice et l'équité
pour les collectivités évidemment la
principale inquiétude des mères c'est la
hausse de leur facture d'énergie et
l'autre modification apporté hier au
budget par les sénateurs c'est
l'augmentation des aides de l'État aux
communes pour payer leurs factures
d'électricité oui c'est entre autres ce
qu'on appelle le filet de sécurité il a
été prolongé en 2023 pour que l'État
puisse continuer à prendre en charge la
moitié de l'augmentation des dépenses
énergétiques des communes les plus en
difficulté d'après le gouvernement il y
a un peu moins de 4000 communes qui ont
déjà bénéficié d'un acompte en 2022 sur
11000 bénéficiaires au total là encore
c'est trop peu pour les sénateurs et
cette fois c'est la commission des
finances qui a proposé d'élargir le
dispositif en quelque sorte en modifiant
les critères fixés par le gouvernement
pour y avoir droit 40% des communes
étaient exclues du dispositif dit la
commission des finances exclue de ce
filet de sécurité donc le Sénat a voté
pour qu'elle puisse théoriquement tout y
prétendre là encore un vote contre la
vie du gouvernement qui lui voudrait
bien limiter cette aide vraiment aux
communes les plus en difficulté
ouvrir trop c'est le cas de le dire le
filet et maille du filet ça c'est un
risque d'exposition des finances
publiques moi j'aimerais pouvoir dire
que l'État peut compenser
l'essentiel de l'augmentation de la
facture des collectivités des
entreprises j'aimerais pouvoir le dire
je mentirais en le disant la réalité
c'est qu'on a ce choc qui nous arrive
comme partout en Europe et partout dans
le monde et qu'il impose que tout le
monde fasse des efforts
le message est assez clair Bernard
Delcros c'est vraiment l'avertissement
du gouvernement d'une mise en danger des
finances publiques est-ce que vraiment
l'État peut tout compenser pour les
communes dans cette crise énergétique
alors je pense que non et et je veux le
redire il faut aider les collectivités
qui en ont le plus besoin face à
l'augmentation du prix des prix en
général et de prix de l'énergie
notamment
d'ailleurs il n'y a pas que l'énergie
les collectivités sont confrontés à
l'augmentation des prix dans beaucoup de
domaines il y a évidemment l'énergie je
vais y revenir c'est votre question mais
beaucoup de communes
ont vu des l'explosion des prix liés à
l'augmentation des matières premières
dans les travaux qu'elles réalisent
souvent les collectivités c'est des
travaux publics ou du bâtiment explosion
des prix des des augmentations de 30 à
40% entre les estimations qui ont été
faites au moment où ces collectivités
ont demandé leur subventions et le
résultat des marchés publics il y a les
produits alimentaires pour la
restauration scolaire donc c'est un
sujet très important et et là
franchement je pense que il faut que
l'État accompagne fortement encore une
fois ce qui en ont le plus besoin je
pense que c'est c'est prioritaires et
donc il y a trois dispositifs qui vont
aider les collectivités dans le budget
2023 et je reviens sur ce qui a été voté
hier il y a pour les petites
collectivités et les tarifs réglementés
un plafonnement de la hausse de
l'électricité il y a cette année
l'amortisseur électricité pour les
grandes collectivités qui va permettre à
l'État de de
prendre en charge 50% du coût
d'électricité au-delà de 325 euros le
mégawattheure et puis le fameux filet de
sécurité qu'on a élargi d'hier et ce
filet de sécurité qu'on a élargi il est
pas il va pas s'adresser à toutes les
collectivités là aussi on s'adresse aux
collectivités qui en ont le plus besoin
on compare l'augmentation du prix de
l'énergie pour faire simple à recettes
de fonctionnement et à l'augmentation
des recettes de fonctionnement des
collectivités si l'augmentation des
recettes de fonctionnement des
collectivités
est suffisante pour absorber
l'augmentation du prix de l'énergie la
collectivité le rat sa charge si ces
recettes ne sont pas suffisantes l'état
vient aidé c'est un bon dispositif et
moi j'ai défendu d'ailleurs nous avions
notre groupe un amendement
identique à celui du rapporteur général
chez défendu l'élargissement du filet de
sécurité ça ne veut pas dire que toutes
les collectivités en bénéficieront
sur ce texte est-ce que ça divise pas un
peu la majorité sénatoriale Samia a
parlé aujourd'hui de la dotation globale
de fonctionnement il y a eu des
divergences entre centrices et
républicains vous nous en avez parlé
pareil sur la suppression de la CVAE la
cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises les républicains étaient
pour un report d'un an les centristes
étaient pour la suppression de la
suppression puisque c'est ce qui
envisageait par le gouvernement il y a
de la friture sur la ligne pourquoi
c'est divergences alors sur sur la
question la DGF nous on était en accord
avec la position du rapporteur général
la commission des finances sur la CV
alors vous savez l'ADN décentristes
c'est pas la discipline avant les
convictions donc on a des convictions on
les défend elle convergent parfois avec
certaines groupes tant mieux mais en
tous les cas on défend de conviction et
donc effectivement il y a eu deux points
de divergence sur des sujets importants
du budget la c.be et la contribution
exceptionnelle sur les super profits
voilà et notre position sur ces deux
sujets LSM sur la cbae la suppression de
la CBE qui est un impôt de production
qui était d'ailleurs un engagement du
Président de la République ne sont pas
opposés au principe en même temps il
faut replacer ce sujet dans le contexte
d'aujourd'hui d'une situation financière
qui est quand même compliquée pour
l'état de la nécessité de redresser les
finances publiques et surtout et surtout
des dépenses supplémentaires que doit
faire l'état on vient d'en parler pour
soutenir les collectivités les
entreprises les ménages face à
l'augmentation des prix donc il nous
semble que le moment n'est pas opportun
pour supprimer la CBE je rappelle et
retarder d'un nom du coup c'était pas
compliqué
que le gouvernement dans un premier
temps avait prévu de la supprimer en
totalité cette année que compte tenu de
la situation et de ce que je viens de
rappeler il avait choisi finalement de
le faire en deux temps 4 milliards cette
année 4 milliards l'année prochaine nous
nous pensons que c'est pas opportun et
qu'il faut d'abord faire face à la crise
à l'augmentation des prix redresser les
finances et regarder ensuite regarder
ensuite cette question des impôts de
production effectivement c'était un
point de différence avec certains
groupes pas avec tous et puis nous avons
eu la question sur la contribution
exceptionnelle sur les super profits là
aussi c'est une mesure d'équité c'est
une mesure de justice c'est une mesure
de solidarité nationale c'est aussi
attention un message qu'on envoie aux
Français alors qu'on demande aux
Français de faire des efforts
considérables face à l'augmentation des
prix notamment de l'énergie et ben moi
je trouve tout à fait légitime juste
équitable que on puisse taxer les très
très grandes entreprises ça ne concerne
pas les petites entreprises et très très
grande entreprise qui font des profits
considérables exceptionnels liés à la
crise c'est une simple mesure d'équité
et encore une fois c'est dans l'ADN du
groupe centriste merci Sam merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous à tout à
l'heure dans le club vous revenez avec
nous dans moins d'une demi-heure on va
aller chez vous on va aller dans le
Cantal justement voir l'actualité on va
retrouver pierre Reynaud au directeur
départemental de l'édition du Cantal du
journal La Montagne bonjour Pierre merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous avec vous on
revient justement puisqu'on était en
train d'en parler sur l'envolée des prix
de l'énergie alors on a parlé des
collectivités qui sont touchées mais
vous allez aussi nous parler des
entreprises
dans le sujet de la flambée des coups
d'énergie on a consacré dans l'édition
du jour de pages aux factures très
salées mais là c'est intéressé nous aux
autres entrepreneurs du Cantal les
crises s'enchaînent pour eux et la
stabilité devient la norme on a on a
rencontré plusieurs entrepreneurs de
notre territoire il y en a un qui lui
disait notamment Olivier tail qui a le
gérant de mécatel une entreprise qui
fabrique des machines industrielles
automatisées au sud de Rilhac sa phrase
est assez forte c'est entre la pénurie
de composants les carnets de commandes
qui s'écroule et l'énergie qui flambent
pour entreprendre aujourd'hui en France
il faut être fou il a pourtant lui
intégré des panneaux photovoltaïques sur
une partie de la toiture ces bâtiments
pour essayer d'alléger la facture
énergétique l'avenir est tout aussi
incertain pour Emmanuel Ebrard à la tête
aussi d'une entreprise mais lui de
taille de pierre de besanteur installé
de l'autre côté du département à
Villedieu qui entre pas lui dans les
critères pour être éligibles aux aides
de l'État alors ma première question
monsieur sénateur du Quentin c'est
quelle solution de court terme pourrait
alléger leurs factures répondre à
l'urgence de la situation
bonjour Pierre Reynaud vous soulevez un
problème qui est tout à fait tout à fait
importante qui touche pas que les
grandes entreprises et Monsieur vu que
vous aviez consacré une double page à
l'entreprise d'Emmanuel Hebrard ça
touche une entreprise de taille de
pierre c'est le cas ça touche des
petites séries j'ai été alerté par par
des des propriétaires de Siri ça touche
des boulangers c'est essentiellement
l'augmentation du prix d'électricité
pour les entreprises dans les machines
fonctionnent à l'électricité c'est vrai
que en 2022 il n'y a pas eu de
dispositifs de mon point de vue
suffisamment efficace pour accompagner
ces entreprises alors ce qui est prévu
en 2023 qui nous paraît vraiment aller
dans le bon sens c'est que pour
l'ensemble des entreprises il y aura un
système de plafonnement en quelque sorte
si je peux dire
dès lors que le mégawattheure dépassera
le prix du mégawattheure dépassera 325
euros l'état prendra en charge 50% du
dépassement donc c'est une aide
importante qui devrait permettre de
soulager les entreprises en tous les cas
je le souhaite et encore une fois je le
redis ce sont aussi des petits artisans
des petites entreprises qui sont
concernées donc c'est extrêmement
important comme on l'a vu pour les
collectivités qu'on est un dispositif
efficace pour ces entreprises je pense
que ce qui appelait l'amortisseur
électricité avec cette prise en charge à
50% par l'État devrait permettre à ces
entreprises de faire face à la hausse du
prix de l'électricité pierre vous avez
une deuxième question
pas forcément à travers une série mais
je vais prendre l'exemple d'une série
c'est que effectivement il y a une
urgence c'est le sujet du moment mais il
y a la prime parce qu'il y a des
entreprises qui renégocie actuellement
leur contrat d'énergie donc non c'est
rapproché des dirigeants de la Syrie
forestera que vous connaissez à Vabre et
elle qui évoque un prix d'électricité
qui sera 8 fois plus cher en 2023 on la
comparant à celle de 2021 avec des
impacts très lourds sur la rentabilité
il ne faut pas s'attendre à des miracles
cette phrase c'est celle des
entrepreneurs du Cantal qui accueillent
modérément les mesures d'aide sur
énergie alors comment les aider
durablement
ces entreprises à faire face à cette
nouvelle crise qui s'ouvre à eux alors
il y a deux sujets dans ce que vous
évoquez il y a l'augmentation des prix
d'électricité à travers les contrats où
il y a un sujet à traiter sur le moyen
et le long terme sur les prix de
l'électricité je reviens pas sur les
mécanismes mais le mécanisme qui est
quand même assez curieux mais là
l'important c'est d'aider ces
entreprises dans l'urgence et je le
redis les dispositifs en place pour les
entreprises en 2022 n'étaient pas à la
hauteur des besoins mais à partir du 1er
janvier
2023 donc on y est il y aura une prise
en charge à hauteur 50% pour toute la
dépense d'électricité dès lors que le
prix du mégawatt-heure dépasse 325 euros
donc je pense honnêtement que en tous
les cas c'est un sujet c'est un une
mesure que nous soutenons au Sénat je
pense que c'est de nature a aidé ces
entreprises donc si le prix est
multiplié par 7 en réalité
d'augmentation électricité il sera pas
multiplié par 7 pour l'entreprise et
l'État prendra en charge 50% de la
hausse dont j'ai parlé
après il y a un sujet à régler
plus long terme sur pourquoi
l'électricité augmente trop comment se
fixe le prix d'électricité on sait que
c'est associé à des tarifs de gaz et
autres mais c'est un sujet qui dépasse
la France donc cette question là il
faudra la traiter mais l'urgence c'est
dès le premier janvier de pouvoir
accompagner ces entreprises pour réduire
finalement leur facture d'électricité
merci Pierre et no merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous on regarde la une
de la montagne dans son édition du
Cantal pris de l'énergie facture trop
salée c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci Pierre Reno à très vite on va
parler du Parlement rural français vous
en êtes le président en amour qu'est-ce
que c'est alors le Parlement rural
français
c'est les membres du Palma rural
français ce sont des acteurs au
quotidien du territoire ruraux et ce qui
fait la richesse du Parlement rural
français c'est que il y a bien sûr des
élus il y a des parlementaires il y a
des collectivités mais ce ne sont pas
seulement des élus beaucoup
d'associations et de fédération
nationale qui au quotidien agissent dans
la ruralité comme Maison Familiale
Rurale on est sur la formation famille
rurale où on est sur la campagnement des
familles de
la jeunesse lumi où on est sur la
question économique des commerces de la
des restaurants des bars de l'hôtellerie
et puis il y a aussi des universitaires
des chercheurs des géographes donc
finalement un ensemble qui vit dans la
ruralité qui agit au quotidien dans la
réalité mais dans une diversité de char
en quelque sorte et c'est ce qui fait la
richesse du Parlement rural et vous
allez rencontrer le ministre dans les
prochaines heures les ministres j'ai
envie de dire puisque également une
ministre spécifiquement en charge de la
ruralité qu'est-ce que vous demandez au
gouvernement on en est où de l'agenda
rural d'Edouard Philippe alors
effectivement nous allons non seulement
rencontrer des ministres mais nous
organisons une session du Parlement
rural
de même à terme au ministère d'ailleurs
dans une salle qui sera aménagée donc il
y en aura une délégation d'environ 70
membres et à peine afin de permettre à
toutes nos fédérations de pouvoir
interagir en quelque sorte directement
avec les ministres concernés Christophe
et Dominique fort et ce que l'on demande
pour la ruralité c'est il y a eu
l'agenda rurale première génération si
je peux dire qui a été quand même une
belle étape franchie c'est-à-dire
vraiment la prise en compte des
problèmes ruraux il y a eu la nomination
d'un secrétariat d'État à la ruralité
avec Joël Giraud et puis maintenant
Dominique c'était une première dans
l'histoire de notre République donc il y
a eu des avancées mais on voit que cette
étape est en franchie et elle était
importante il faut aller plus loin et
donc ce que l'on demande c'est un plan
d'ampleur en faveur de la ruralité
autour de trois piliers les services
c'est la priorité parce que les services
c'est les critères c'est le critères
d'attractivité de la ruralité l'accès à
la santé d'accès à l'éducation la
mobilité au numérique etc je je n'y
reviens pas il y a un deuxième pilier
autour des collectivités locales parce
que les collectivités locales en
territoire rural elles doivent porter le
développement pour réussir la mutation
des territoires ruraux et arriver à
notre objectif de rééquilibrer les
populations sur le territoire national
et puis un troisième pilier autour du
soutien au commerce à l'artisanat à ses
petites entreprises qui font le maillage
des territoires ruraux et donc nous
allons les uns et les autres domaines
échanger avec des ministres sur ces
perspectives pour la ruralité ouvrir des
perspectives pour la ruralité pour les
jeunes pour les familles qui viennent
s'installer et pourquoi pas et pourquoi
pas et ce que c'est ce que je
souhaiterais à titre personnel et en
tous les cas nous pour transmettre
message et pourquoi pas une grande loi
d'orientation et de programmation pour
la ruralité pour franchement avoir une
vision et donner des perspectives à la
ruralité et aux gens qui veulent y vivre
demain quelle est la réponse du
gouvernement merci beaucoup Bernard
delco notre invité ce matin dans 20
minutes dans le club des territoires on
reviendra longuement sur cette journée
d'Emmanuel Macron hier avec les maires 4
heures Porte de Versailles et la
réception de 1000 d'entre eux à l'Élysée
on va en parler mais on va en parler
tout de suite avec l'invite à qui vous
succède c'est Michael de la fosse le
maire de Montpellier